感谢三月后服
整中的我这个游斗机
这是我用了一年
黑纯和六年酸的素颜
有一种每天吃燕锅
一样出来的心意保慢吃感
虽然这样说了很自愿
但是真的我的毛孔也
你之前好很多
想要快速渐少多多一口
松毛孔
可以老面服的姐妹
都可以这样来操作
但是明赶机的姐妹
千万不要尝试
先用一个脚致条理水
这也不很关键
可以帮我们
再谢教练
上的那种脑肺脚致
打开皮肤通道
叫我们游皮
除了让大脚致就很容易堆进起来
毛孔也容易被独注
很多时候用一些
乎乎可以你觉得没有效果
其实根本就是那个乎乎品
没有被皮肤吸收
全都独在外面
反而门出了一连的闭口粉丝
它其实是一瓶酸水
里面是要螃蟹一的水洋酸
我一般就是把它
倒在眼片上好像千千
你的暗暗在有时候
这种配合面片的
用法就不要去挫了很容易把皮肤挫坏
里面会为了一堆修户尾稳成分
所以可以一边出通毛孔
一边很温和的
给皮肤进行一个
好光
一个脚致层健康的油皮
其实皮肤看起來
会是非常的通透的
毛孔通唱
后续的活动品材
能够被更好吸收
你买目的品花的钱
也不会被浪费掉
我的绿人家的特地方
是非常好的
所以这个脚致条理
我会避开这一片
然后其他的地方
都会进行的按照
然后这一瓶水
它是早晚都可以用的
但是我等早上
我们还是一定要做好防柴
早上用后续跟些离行
或者是可以要化的成分
也会让他们的效果更加的好
也可以让后续上装
不那么容易错
你装消不更加服务贤
我很久之前
看到一个明星化装十分
小胎的油架领化装之前
一定会师傅神薪水
装改会更好看
那其实跟我们早上用小字条
一层的原理是一样的
现在的脸是
完全的干了
但来图
两到三部的修顾顶
可以用三修也可以用预装
或者是并无精华
都可以
甚至你想再进节一点
再猛一点
有烟鲜的精华也可以
但是
一定要选择
像这种
苏感很清爽的
因为我们是游戏
有一些比较濃稠的精华
它里面其实加了很多的增稠技
干体用会觉得很暴时
但我们用了
会觉得忽了一脸
特别不舒服
这也不主要就是给皮膚进行一个正经书
因为我们前面用了
海酸的产品
后面要用A强度还是有一些的
在酸人之前加上修顾精华
就能做到四两部签金
降低翻证机会
一件小刺激
现在修顾精华已经洗手完
我们再来用一个
A强精华
这支里面加了0.1的A强
这两边大家要说一下
A乘在发生作用时候
是新要转化成A强
再转化成A强
才在我们的点像起作用
所以A强会比A强要少一步
更不害转化成A强
而且A强还能平衡
我们脸上的军军
非常适合那种
反胆不复长斗的游动机
这个是我之前跟我们分享过
很多次的
他们家的地方双黑精华
那其实用这个也是可以的
他们两个就是资动点不一样
这里面是0.3%的A强加倍A强
这一频里面是0.1%的A强加倍A强
如果是想要重演配料的
属应起宝贝就可以像这个
如果是脸上斗斗B口黑头
比较多的宝宝
都可以去这个
今天的这个晚间或服
你们手里面有什么A
就可以用什么A
这个没有关系
我只跟你们分享一下这两个区别
因为可能会有很多宝贝问
因为这个是新品
我最近很想用证明
因为它的司法会更加清爽
上来里面上会更快的洗手
没有什么名义
三岸护服的话
那里面晚上我就不会用
很多的A辣椎椎椎
一帮这个
这个真的几乎好
好快
这后用一个
修护面上进行一个风险修护
降低我们翻成绩
因为听得晚上
又是A弥是酸
真的下半抹的
我大家配功效护服的面双
一般就是这几块
这个呢
就是如果点上要斗一的话
你就用这个
然后这个的测重点就是开朗
然后它的敷感是
这几块当中
我根据的最新手
然后兄弟就不用说的
就是某药打开
所以今天晚上我用它
但是你们可以按照自己的洗
号去洗这两个
也是用可以的
然后这一屏呢
它就会更资论
这个我秋冬孤的比较多
或者是用某药翻车的脸上
又洗洗又干涠的
它就可以快速地帮我
这就回答
今天的晚节
护服就这么很简单的完成了
只要是对酸和A辣椎椎的姐妹
就可以试试这个酸椎厚服
尤其是单用酸
单用A已经到了
护服瓶键
其实宝贝你们更要这么试试
这一套服服会直接帮你打开
新世界大门